welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation titled
detection and monitoring of mutations
from liquid biopsies a clinical study
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
monica sado the senior development
scientist from the genomics and cellular
research at sativa for complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the tab at the top of your screen now if
any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them through the q a box our speaker
will address your questions following
the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming monica
sedol i will now turn the presentation
over to her welcome monica
good morning and good afternoon everyone
thank you for the introduction my name
is monica seidel and i'm part of rnd
team at sativa in genomic and diagnostic
solution business segment
our mission at sativa is to accelerate
and advance therapeutics and by doing so
we believe that we are getting closer to
the situation where access to a life
changing therapy is widely available
and how do we achieve our mission we
achieve our mission by providing
the customers with tools and services
for diagnostic related research and we
also maintain
a wide network of collaboration
including academic institutions where
this kind of research is taking place
today i will be talking about liquid
biopsies and their application in cancer
diagnostic this is a rapidly growing
field uh fueled by uh
current focus and development and
advances in precision medicine
so what would be covered in my
presentation
as an introduction i will briefly cover
liquid biopsies and then i will describe
different type of nucleic acids that can
be found
in
in the bloodstream and they have
obviously different relevance and
applicability into biomarker profiling
and then we'll dive a bit deeper into
our cell free dna
nucleic acid and the only type of
analyte that is currently used in
clinical practice
we will consider challenges associated
with liquid biopsies and we also
will discuss some avenues that are being
undertaken in order to overcome those
challenges
the kolma presentation
will focus on results of a study that we
conducted
in which we tried to answer the question
whether a site selection assisted
extraction of cell free dna
can allow for higher sensitivity of
cancer-associated mutation detection
the term liquid
biopsy covers the collection
of bodily fluids for the
purpose of genetic profiling
and there's a number of different bodily
fluids can that can be collected for the
purpose uh including urine cerebrospinal
fluid uh saliva but this is the blood
that is being currently used and
in clinical practice and is mostly
investigated
the first report
describing the presence of nucleic acids
in the bloodstream goes back to 1948
however at this particular point in time
the discovery was completely unnoticed
and put to rest for
roughly another 15 years when another
report
showed that
fetal dna can be found and detected in
maternal plasma
this discovery laid the foundation for a
non-invasive prenatal screening that is
currently being used
in a clinical practice for detection of
chromosomal unemployed in pregnancies
and this amazing success that the liquid
biopsies achieved in this field
triggered extensive research and to the
possibility of using
liquid biopsies for
biomarker profiling and cancer
cardiovascular disorders autoimmune
diseases diabetes or for early detection
of organ rejection and transplant
allergy
excuse me as for cancer
related use for liquid biopsies their
applicability is being researched in
both early and advanced stage cancer and
for early stage cancer it's mostly
evaluated in terms of being a screening
tool so we are trying to find find out
whether liquid biopsies
are able to detect cancer and otherwise
healthy individuals so in those patients
that do not present any clinical
manifestation of the disease but cancer
is already developing
and although there is a one fda approved
test for a screening of early cancer and
this is a very challenging uh field and
this is mostly due to the limited
sensitivity of detection cancer of
detecting cancer associated mutations
because in an early stage cancer the
amount of tumor the right fraction of
the circulation is extremely low the
reported sensitivity
varies depending on the cancer type and
cancer location between 30 and 80
percent meaning that the risk of false
negative results
is extremely high
similar challenges
apply to the use of liquid biopsies in
the detection of minimal residual
disease so this would correspond to the
detection of cancers
the much higher success rate for liquid
biopsies is found in advanced cancer and
this is reflected in the current
guidelines advocating the use of liquid
biopsies for genetic profiling and
circumstances where tissue biopsy is not
available
and this applies to advanced cancers
such as lung cancer
prostate cancer or breast cancer
and another field which holds a lot of
promise for liquid biopsies is for
monitoring purposes
and this will be monitoring how well the
therapy is working and also monitoring
and the
actuations and unfortunately happen in
majority of patients following the first
line of therapy
and what needs to be said is the biggest
advantage of liquid biopsy is its
potential to uncover the whole
genetic landscape of the tumor
all happened in the tumor in a spatial
and temporal
manner and for that reason
um
[Music]
there's a number of different
cell free nucleic acid that can be found
in this circulation if we concentrate on
rna there are two main groups
one is non-coding rna and the second is
coding rna so coding a renamer is
represented by a messenger rna which
encodes protein and this is a minor
fraction in the circulation and in in
its intact form is almost exclusively
found in exosomes uh the reason behind
it is when
mrna is released into the bloodstream
it's rapidly degraded by nucleases and
for that reason um constitutes a rather
unsuitable
analyte for biomarker profiling
among non-coding rnas which is a very
diverse set of of molecules
but majority of them with a few
exceptions are responsible for gene
expression modulation it is the micro
rna which attracted the highest amount
of attention
those are small molecules of around 18
to 24 base per base burst uh long
and
they are quite stable in the circulation
due to the to the fact that they are
being uh in complexes with protein
and they are responsible for
translational silencing of genes and
this is done through a microarrangement
binding to a
three prime untranslated region in their
messenger rnase
so one microrna can target the number of
messenger rnase and this is because this
interaction happens for non
non-full complementarity of two strands
and this is a heavily researched area
number of reports show a specific cancer
related signature profile of micro rna
expression
now if we go into dna we can divide the
dna found into the circulation based on
its origin so it's either mitochondrial
dna or selfie dna that is represented by
genomic dna released by a number of
cells cells
in the organism
and 100 dna research is in in an infancy
and it's not currently used in any of
the of the analytical methods for
biomarker profiling although there are a
number of reports uh showing uh that
it's exclusively released by tumor cells
and might be
used for cancer detection
on the contrary
cell free dna is already in clinical
practice
is used for a non-invasive prenatal
screening
is used
in circumstances with tissue biopsy is
not
feasible in advanced cancer
and is also used in passive screening
for colorectal cancer in patients which
i'm able to undergo colonoscopy
diving deeper into selfrid dna
characteristics uh first of all it is uh
released into the bloodstream through
active and passive mechanisms and those
active mechanisms are not fully
understood
as for passive release is mostly done
by the way of necrosis and hypothesis
uh sulfur dna represents the pull of
genomic dna released by a number of
different cells including
inflamed cells tumor cells fetal cells
in pregnancy but it is believed that the
majority of social dna and the
bloodstream is of hematopoietic origin
and in terms of the size of cell free
dna the peak
is centered around 170 baseballs this is
corresponding to the size of the
nucleosome
uh and this size profile of itself dna
you can see on the right hand side of
the slide this is a electrophorogram
created with the use of bioanalyzer and
you showed that the size of sulfate dna
ranges between 100 to 300 base pair but
indeed the peak is around 170 pacers
there is number of reports um
showing that
sulfur dna is fragmented
in a different way depending on its
origin
and what is also important and initially
this was
something that was considered to use in
cancer screening and detection is that
the amount of cell free dna
is highly um
is highly increased in advanced cancer
however
it turned out that
this high amount of cell creatine is
also associated with other conditions
such as pregnancy
autoimmune disorders or following
strenuous exercise
so if you have a look at this slide
which is a very busy slide and i have no
intention to go for all the uh
publications that are being listed in
the table
i just wanted to attract the
attention of the audience to the fact
that
selfie dna which is derived from tumor
is highly fragmented
and all those publications i left in the
table uh give three conclusions uh first
of all the fact that the amount of
cell-free dna in advanced cancer is much
higher than healthy individuals
secondly and that there is a clear shift
in the size of cell free dna in cancer
patients there were lower fragments
somewhere around or somewhere below 150
base
and thirdly that those fragments uh they
are smaller than virgin tumor fraction
so the biggest challenge
of
cell free dna and its utility
permutation detection is sensitivity
this sensitivity uh limited sensitivity
originates of course from the end point
detection i say that they are being
currently used for biomarker profiling
but it's also inherent to the specific
characteristic that selfie dna possesses
uh so first of all the amount of selfie
dna in that stream it's uh particularly
low but what is even lower is the
fraction that derived from the tumor
an early stage cancer dysfunction
is within point zero one percent
and goes up to thirty percent in um
apostatic uh advanced uh cancer
on the top of this if we want to use
liquid biopsies to monitor uh tumor
evolution you can imagine that those
clonal cells within the tumor then
constitute even lower fraction of the
tumor itself
and what doesn't help the situation is
quite often that during plasma
processing and there is a significant
release of genomic dna from white
cells that further
dilutes tumor device fraction
and what i mentioned earlier is also the
fact that self-free dna that comes from
cancer cells is highly fragmented and
also is damaged meaning that sometimes
er is present in a single stranded form
or in double stranded form where one of
the strands is nicked
this imposes a lot of challenges because
uh
almost majority of the majority of
currently use
next generation library preparation
methods use uh double-stranded library
preps which unfortunately
are not allowing to capture those small
fragments and those next fragments
and the endpoints
in the endpoint library and
an ngs
analysis
and if we now go to the different
technologies they're being used for uh
detection of mutations i listed both two
different ones uh one is digital droplet
pcr and the second one is targeted ngs
you can see that both of those methods
they have a
different limit of detection
and this limit of detection varies
depending on some uh technological
changes that are being implemented to
the to the standard uh
technique in order to lower limit of
detection for ngs for example that would
be use of unique molecular identifiers
that would allow to eliminate
pcr-created errors or the use of
bioinformatic tools that allow to
eliminate sequencing errors
and nevertheless the first question that
everyone will probably ask if the limit
of detection for digital drug with pcr
is so low why isn't it this technique
exclusively used for biomarker profiling
and the reason behind this is that
although it has extremely low
sensitivity this method requires uh
requires that the user knows the
mutation up prior to the detection so
you need to know what we are looking for
when you are using when you are using
digital pcr
in terms of targeted ngs this upper
knowledge of mutation identity is not
needed what is needed is the identity of
the gene that we want to investigate and
there are not a number of different
panels um
that allow sequencing genes that are
well known to be associated with cancer
um so on the previous slide i discussed
the challenges uh associated with
typical characteristics uh that uh cell
free dna has
and there are a number of unused avenues
that can be undertaken uh to mitigate
those problems
so for example uh for the release of
genomic dna
and the increased yield in cell for dna
extraction
uh it has been now advised uh to use
specific type of
blood collection tubes that allow to
limit genomic dna release from white
blood cells and increase the stability
of cell free dna
again for library preparation
it has been suggested that
in some cases single stranded library
preparations
might be more
suitable in order to capture those
necked and single stranded fragments of
of dna
and then i already mentioned
the use of bioinformatics tools to
eliminate sequencing error and ngs
and also use of
unique molecular and identifiers
to eliminate pcr amplification errors
and there is also
another
another point at
at which we can try to uh to mitigate
the problems related to selfie dna and
this is the extraction
um so here at sativa we develop uh sorry
extract of cell free dna kit and that is
based on magnetic beat technology
and has uh three features that we
believe
and allow to
to increase the sensitivity in endpoint
essay and those three critical points is
the fact that the kit allows to
allow allows to capture a low fragments
in a very efficient way
the kit allows to extract cell free dna
to the high extent and the third
aspect of the kit is the fact that uh it
allows for elimination of genomic dna
carryover
this principle is illustrated on the
electro ferrogram that you can see on
the right hand side of the slide
so if we have a look uh the blue trace
represents uh plasma extracted with our
kit uh but before extraction the plasma
will spike with dna ladder
and this dna ladder is represented in
the green and the green trace
so when you have a look at the
efficiency of extraction of small
fragments you can see that the blue line
overlaps very well with the green line
in lower molecular weight
range
for example for 50 and 100 base pairs
and when you have a look
at the higher molecular weight
recovery you can see that about 300 base
pairs the recovery declines rapidly and
at 2
kb this recovery is around 20 or below
20 meaning that the um carrier of
genomic dna is minimized
so we of course wanted to see how our
kid performs against leading brands uh
so we benchmark the kid against uh mark
max selfrey dna kid which is
manufactured by thermofish scientific
and we also tested the kid against a
cayenne mini lotket which is
manufactured by cryogen
um so in terms of kyogen kit this is a
silica base kit that is not very easy to
be automated it can only be automated on
instruments manufactured by kyogen
in terms of magma kits this is a very
similar formula to citrificate is based
on magnetic bead technology which allows
for automation
so if we concentrate on the sulfur dna
yield that can be seen on this graph you
can see that there is not much
difference in the extract and efficiency
between three different kits they are
pretty much
similar
uh however uh when you have to do
genomic dna carry over uh we have an
obvious advantage in the field it is
certificate that allows to significantly
reduce the presence of regenerative dna
uh in the
uh in the and the extract um
obtained from
patient serum
of course we are very encouraged from
those results but
the main question that we ask is whether
those key performance characteristics
that i just described for our kid
allow
to achieve higher sensitivity of
mutation detection in clinically
relevant scenario
and for that reason
and so to answer the question uh we had
designed a small study that involved
four patients and they were all
diagnosed with an advanced stage lung
cancer they donated blood this blood was
a process and plasma was extracted
the plasma was subjected to
library preparation and tumor profiling
was done using targeted ngs
so a bit more about patient
stratification and why we decided to go
with patients with non-small cell lung
cancer
so first of all this is the concept that
unfortunately is usually detected in a
very advanced stage and the reason
behind this because first of all there
are no screening
tests
for this cancer and secondly
the cancer usually is asymptomatic
and starts giving symptoms
symptoms with metastasis already
occurred
the genetic profiling
is
currently using clinical practice in
order to discover mutations that can be
targeted to a specific type of therapy
and this genetic profiling is a device
uh
for
testing the mutation and
the mutations in five genes which are
listed in this table and this includes
egfr alk ross one
uh brass
and ntrk
all those uh genes they called for
protein kinases and all all of those
protein cases kindness they have
specific inhibitors can can be used to
treat uh to treat patients
and what is also important and this is
the other reason why we decided to go
for uh
for those uh for those cohort of
patients is the fact that uh in advanced
lung cancer in circumstances with tissue
biopsy is not available liquid biopsy uh
is advocated uh by uh currently uh
current by current clinical guidelines
and the next and very important aspect
of this cancer is unfortunate
resistance that occurs in the majority
of patients following first-line target
therapy
and this is specifically true from
patients that
are positive for mutation in egfr
and
usually within 12 months all of those
patients develop
secondary resistance and the second
resistance is either related to
additional mutation in the egfr gene
itself
or after some bypass mechanism that for
example involves amplification and mats
in matte gene
okay
so
the plasma that was obtained from those
patients
was extracted using
three kits and we used the same kids as
i discussed on previous slides so this
was the magma skit from climate visual
scientific
and a kyogen
kit
kiwam
which is based on silica columns
and
all patients but one uh were processed
with all three kids only patient one was
processed with sativa and kyogen kit and
this is this was due to the limitation
in sample
volume um
[Music]
the extract
were analyzed
using capillary capillary
electrophoresis on by analyzer and maybe
we first concentrate on the right hand
side of the slide and we see three
electro ferrograms and the green trace
uh represents uh sativa extract the blue
trace represent mac max extract and the
orange one is from hyagen
as you can see here the amount of cell
free dna so the main peak centered
at around 170 base per is similar
between three different kits
however if you have a look at a genomic
dna
peak that would represent anything above
700 base spray you can see that this is
uh present in um both kaioshin and
macmax extracts however as far as i t
because it's almost completely
accent
when we go to the left-hand side of the
slide and this is the summary of the
results so the top uh graph represents
the cell phone dna yields
separated by the patient and by the kids
and even though there's a lot of
diversity in the extraction profile
you can see that pretty much overall the
performance of all three kits
is similar
and the clear difference
is when we go to genomic dna
contamination this is summarized in the
lower graph you can see that this is the
scientific kit that allows
to limit and genomic dna presence in the
extract
okay
um so all of those extracts were
subjected to a library preparation
and this um library preparation um that
we performed i used the total volume of
all samples
and the targeted sequencing was done
using island tolerant technology and the
targeted panel that we use is the panel
that was developed by biosept and it's
called biocell target selector ngs lung
panel
it allows to sequence 12 genes
that are well known to be related to
lung cancer
what needs to be said at this point is
that
library preparation
sequencing and data analysis was
performed at biosearch
and so what you see on the slide those
are results from
targeted ngs
and i'm going to discuss those results
in different subsequent slides but maybe
we can just concentrate
and compare the mutational frequency
between patients and between between
that
were used for extraction
as you can see in all cases from patient
four to patient one it is a sativa kit
that allows uh to detect mutation at the
higher frequency
and this
obviously
indicates and that when plasma is
processed with our kit
the extract is an origin tumor derived
and the right fraction
what you can see in the lower uh table
this is the analytical sensitivity of
the target selector and you can see that
for uh hotspot uh single nucleotide
variants uh deletions and insertions
and the limit of detection goes to point
one percent
uh for the novel mutations this limit of
detection is at five excuse me it's 0.5
okay
let's now try to dive a bit deeper into
uh into each of the patients so
let's concentrate on patient two and
four both of those patients uh were
found positive uh for uh mutation and b
raf kinase and this is the mutation at
the position 600 which uh which results
in the replacement of valine with
aspartic acid
and this mutation is a phosphomatic
mutation means that even though the
protein is not phosphorylated uh the
presence of negatively and negatively
charged aspartic acids make the protein
active
and through this activity uh the kinase
activates downstream effectors so
activates mark kinase and
this signaling
leads to the uncontrolled growth and
proliferation of the cells
and this is a very well known mutation
for melanoma and not that prevalent in
non-small
cell lyme cancer i think it's only
visible it's only present two percent of
the patients so so quite rare
and nevertheless
which is quite beneficial for the
patients there is a targeted therapy and
this targeted therapy is both approved
in the european union and and in the
united states
and involves the use of two drugs
targeting
two different kinases uh so the the
first drug uh targets beer kinase the
second drug uh targets a map kinase
and what you can see on the on the table
on the right this is the table taken
from novartis website with a
manufacturer of both of both drugs you
can see the clear benefit for those
patients
where you can see that
overall survival has increased to 20 to
24 months
what i wanted to concentrate on those
slides i wanted to analyze again and go
and slightly deeper into the genomic dna
carry over the yield of cell free dna
and how those two things translate into
mutation on frequency detected in our
essay
so when we start from patient four you
can see that sativa is the best in terms
of self-dna yields and
of course the best in terms of
minimizing genomic dna contamination
and in this particular instance the
mutation of the frequency detected and
sativa extra is twice as high as in
competitors
and
but i think what we need to concentrate
is patient to have a lot of patient
patient to
the yield
extracted dissimilar between three kids
and you can see that the amount of
selfie dna is very low in this patient
and again you can see the genomic dna
contamination is the lowest
in
in samples extracted with sativa kit
however
or maybe what's important is that the
mutation i love frequency
for extract
extra
process with sativa it's almost seven
times higher than what the competitors
get
and this brings us about the brinks only
one conclusion that
the reduction in genomic dna
contamination is specifically important
in circumstances of what cell to dna is
is a limiting factor
okay let's now discuss the results for
patient one and patient three um
and they are both found positive for
mutation and tumor suppressor protein 53
and this is the protein which is quite
often mutated in many different in many
different cancers
not so prevalent in non-small cell lung
cancer very prevalent in a cancer lung
cancer associated with smoking
the protein is composed of three domains
with dna binding domain and most
important photo suppressor activity
of this protein and also
this domain
is um
is
targeted by a number of of mutations
that are well known associated with
cancer so this is a mutation hot spot
those mutations occur and
conserve residues that are listed on
this slide
and one of those conserved residues is
mutated in patient one uh please let me
remind you that patient one uh was only
a process would look at scientific due
to the sample limitation
and i want to concentrate on patient
three because this is slightly uh
slightly more more um
controversial and slightly more
difficult to explain the results so when
we consider um
mad max kit and
the extract from magmax kit
we didn't detect any mutation
in this extract
when we have a look at the cytivo kit it
detects the mutation and that is one of
the hot spot mutation in well-known
conserved residue
uh residue
however now going to kayaking kit we can
see that the text mutation and this
mutation is not a hotspot mutation
and
the mutation outlet frequency is 0.35
percent
and this means that
the mutation
frequency is unfortunately below the
level of detection for novel
um
standard nucleotide variants and in this
circumstance the clinical scenario this
mutation would be considered
inconclusive result and would have to be
repeated but please write me in mind
that there will be no way of repeating
it because the whole extract has been
already used for targeted sequencing
and now if we uh dive slightly deeper
deeper and and mutation on the frequency
and we uh we
will have a look uh at this frequency uh
considering the cell for dna yields and
genomic dna contamination the sample
let's concentrate on sample
three where we don't see any concordance
between three kids and as you can see um
kyogen appears to be the best here in
terms of the recovery of selfie dna
while a sativa is quite comparable to
mathematics
the major difference that we see is in
genomic dna contamination again you can
see that minimal contamination with city
bucket
however quite high with mad max and let
me remind you that this is actually the
mad max
kit in which extract no mutation is
being detected
so from those results we can
draw one important conclusion that site
selection-based
extraction allows to detect mutation
associated with cancer in circumstances
where
where those mutations can be can be
missed when other non-site selection
types of extraction
are implemented
okay
so just to summarize the whole
presentation
we know that targeted analysis of cell
free dna is overdue in clinical practice
is widely used for non-invasive prenatal
screening
we also know that is currently
recommended to use
cell free dna for genetic profiling and
advanced cancer and circumstances with
tissue biopsy is not available
a very important aspect of liquid
biopsies and the one that holds
the highest amount of promise is the
fact that it has the potential
and to uncover a full uh genetic
landscape of the evolving tumor so it
can it can allow for comprehensive uh
decision regarding therapy at the
beginning of the treatment but also
allows to quickly change the the
therapeutic
approach once the resistance mutation
appear
the biggest challenge in the analysis of
selfie dna is the fact that
it constitutes a minor fraction of the
circulation and
the fact that cancer associated
mutations are found at an extremely low
level
um
from those experiments that i share with
you uh it is obvious that size selection
assisted extraction of sulfur dna allows
to enrich for tumor derived fraction
and this enrichment and tumor derived
fraction allows to detect mutations in
circumstances
when
other kids fail to detect it
okay
i think this is it for me and now it's
time for
questions and answers thank you
thank you monica for that
wonderful present movement we will now
move to the q a portion of this
presentation and as a reminder to our
audience members please submit your
questions via the q a box
and monica we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
all right
question is
is sarah extract a cell free dna kit
compatible with serum samples
yes it is compatible in fact it's it's
highly recommended for those type of
samples and
the reason behind it is that serum
samples are notorious for genomic dna
contamination and as i presented
our kids
is able to remove to some extent this
genome dna contamination
thank you so much now in clinical
applications what is a preferable sample
type is it serum or is it plasma
um i believe that there's a general
consensus in the field that plasma is
preferred sample in clinical
applications and this is based on a
number of reports showing that
mutation alert frequency
and the detection rate of cancer
associated biomarkers is much higher in
plasma samples compared to much serum
samples uh what's probably important
that we shouldn't dismiss serum samples
completely they are very important in
retrospective studies for biomarker
discovery in large cohorts of of
patients on bio biobank samples
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
now monica is blood always the best type
of input sample for cancer detection
well as i said the amount of
and then on the cancer type uh the stage
of cancer the location of the tumor
so there are particular type of cancers
that probably are
not very well suited to be detected in
blood and this will be bladder and
prostate cancer it appears that urine is
more suitable sample
for example for brain cancers it seems
that cerebral spinal fluid might be more
suitable
thank you so much will liquid biopsy
fully replace
the tissue biopsy in the near future
interesting question
uh yes it's quite controversial
interesting um i don't think this is the
case i would i perceive myself
a liquid biopsy as complementary
approach to tissue biopsy
the problem lies in the fact that liquid
biopsy is not universally applied to all
cancers it's not
it will be difficult to replace tissue
biopsy for example because
tumor biopsy provides you the material
to perform histological assessment of
the tumor and this is the main approach
for
subtyping of the cancer
and again in early cancer the
sensitivity of the detection using a
liquid biopsy is quite valuable and low
and so for those reasons i think this
should be treated as a complementary
approach
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions our next audience
member wants to know what is the plasma
input volume for sarah extracta's cell
free dna kit and how does it correspond
to the volume of blood needed
okay so so you can get around four mils
of plasma from 10 mils of blood
and the kit has been validated for 0.5
mil input up to 4 mils
thank you so much we have time for one
more question what is the average amount
of cfdna per one milliliter of plasma
oh this this varies greatly and and
obviously it depends on the particular
condition that a donor is in
but also it depends on the
pre-analytical and analytical approaches
but if we concentrate on the condition
of the of the donor
this would be in high picograms to maybe
15 20 nanograms per ml of plasma and
healthy donors and why in advance cancer
this would probably go for over
100 nanograms per ml of plasma
however i think there should be a bit of
caution supplies because applied because
for example after strenuous exercise the
amount of um cellular dna in plasma can
go also above 100 nanograms per ml of
plasma
monitor thank you so much for your time
today and for your outstanding
presentation once again would you like
to provide our audience with any closing
remarks before we go
um i i think i said everything that i
want i just want uh everyone
thank everyone for listening and if you
have any particular questions that i
haven't answered or they were not
something was not clear during the
presentation
please feel free to contact me and write
an email to my email address that i
believe was displayed at the end of the
presentation
thank you so much and i will ditto that
statement thank you to our audience and
please know that any questions that
weren't addressed at this q a will be
addressed via email by the presenter and
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months so
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who may be interested in
today's topic and don't miss out on
other presentations on the agenda visit
the agenda tab in the auditorium for a
full listing thank you again for your
participation until next time stay safe
and stay healthy take care everyone
bye-bye thank you everyone bye